[Music]
all right let's go out to eight mile at
Detroit Rock City and talk to an what's
up
an oh not much thanks for taking my call
Dr Jen of course what's up um well I
have a some dilemas or problems um I've
been married for 25 years and um my
husband works on the road so he is out
of the home Monday through um Friday
return Friday evening um oh dang so how
long's you been doing that um since
let's see it's about 15 years now he's
been doing that W yes do you have kids
so uh we do but they are growing so this
is where the problem really lies now
they're growing or they're grown they're
growing so 25 and 22 so they're out of
the home now okay okay oh so You' you've
been a single parent for 15 years I have
yeah what is your husb very active one
at that so they kept me very busy and um
so it wasn't as difficult as it is now
for me um with him on the road all the
time what's he do he is he a driver no
he works on the high electrical line
power
lines so he's like an actual actual
stud yeah yeah gosh
dude okay so he's gone and so now that
the kids are gone I'm spending a lot
obviously time at home by myself and and
feeling very lonely and um it's it's
very difficult um to throw a little
Notch into everything um he uh we live
on the Family Farm And so he has this
desire to continue this tradition of
farming with his you know that's been in
the farm for generations and
generations and so his weekends are
pretty much occupied with farming also
yeah so
here's what I would recommend youall do
if you haven't already I would recommend
that EU call some
sort
of romantic getaway
weekend would he do
that at certain times of the year you
know obviously right now it's hard
because it's harvest time so it's even
more amped up than normal when does
Harvest Time roll
out um it usually starts anywhere from
September and goes through depending on
the weather um through
November okay I want you to put November
15th on the
calendar November 21st on the calendar
and that's going to go right into deer
huntting season I get it
but here's what has to happen you all
have to get together and
say we've been married for a quarter
Century 15 years ago you went to do this
work and I raised these kids essentially
on my
own I want us to make a
plan for the back half of our Lives how
old are you right
now I'm 44 okay you get about halfway
done at some point you have to have the
courage to say I don't want to continue
doing this in two more years or five
more
years I want to paint a new picture of
what the back half of our life is going
to look like and I have expressed that a
little bit um and and even come up with
some ideas of strategies of things that
we could possibly do um to help some of
this
situation one you know obviously he
can't walk away from all these years
that he's put into this company either
he absolutely 100% could a
retirement could care
less he's not going to lose all the
retirement is
he part of it he would yes
okay what's what's what's the number
what's the number for his
wife well I'm willing up to give up my
job and relocate where he does most of
the work to make this work okay so to me
that's a lot because I also have
established you know Rel ships and
things at my work but I can do my work
other places um the need that the line
of work I'm in there's a need everywhere
so I can find a job
easily I don't know what the when that
was brought up it was like well then we
have to purchase another house and are
we going to be able to afford it and I
do all the finances y'all are going
about this all
backwards y'all are going through you
are saying you know I'm kind of what
what if we thought about and like this
is and immediately he'll kick into
problem solving mode as most men do and
he'll come up with a reason or two or
three why this won't
work and then you cash
out so my question to you is how much
longer under the current Arrangement are
you in
for not much that's right
my guess is you are way closer to the
end than you are letting on or that your
friends probably even know
absolutely
and my gut tells me he has a second life
somewhere not with a family or anything
like I'm saying he's running around has
seven kids somewhere else but he has a
whole other life that you're not a part
of is that fair MH and part of you is
really pissed off that he missed your
kids's
life resentment yep yep at the same time
you're really grateful that he's
provided a good living for everybody
Fair correct y both and
and I believe with all my guts that
there is a season when a and I'm going
to over genderize this so everybody hold
your breath when men go to work and do
things they hate away from people they
love because they have to get something
done I believe that I can imagine in
2008 in Detroit saying I'm going to go
find something to do because the world
was imploding around everybody I get
that 2009 is about right yeah I get that
and I think you can cheat on your wife
with your
job I think you can cheat on your wife
with a golf
course I think you can cheat on your
wife with with any number of
things the challenge here is you can't
control any of that what you can control
is how clear you're being and I don't
want you for the sake of not rocking the
boat or the sake of not causing you know
this or
that I think it's time to be very very
clear and it will probably be like a ton
of bricks out of left field for him you
think or no yes absolutely abolutely
okay I think you have to own that
because you probably should have had
this conversation seven years ago Fair
yeah yeah why didn't
you you're not supposed to ask why
questions but I'm just
curious just because I was so active
with my own career at the time and very
busy and then like like I said the kids
were in and out for a while and then
they're finally like established their
own lives and then I just felt like I
was left in the
dust did you also leave him in the
dust um no but I don't schedule my life
around him anymore because he doesn't do
the same for
me so let me ask you a hard question are
you
done
no convince me or
not when we're together I love the time
that we have well of course I mean it
has no strings to it you can have a
weekend rendevu and fall under whatever
religious
Dominion that you've ascribed to and
then you can go about having whatever
job and day and life and friends you
want just because you have fun on the
weekend with somebody doesn't mean your
marriage is
solid I definitely know it lacks some
communication otherwise I would
have that was awesome I mean it's kind
of lacking a little you know yeah yes
you've been keeping this secret for 10
years
now what what keeps you from quitting
your job and showing up on the doorstep
of the apartment he lives in or the
hotel he lives been living out of for 15
years and say I miss you so much I can't
breathe
probably I to be honest what I've
created for
myself MH just the stability of being
able to you know I'm independent like I
can support myself I know but to what
end you're flexing for yourself right
into the end of your
marriage
yep like your words are saying no I want
to fix this I want to solve this but
every action I see from both of you is
like no no this thing is just like a
cool weekend
arrangement I think in the back of our
heads both of us are just like
when we can retire which is in still
seven years this will be
different what's GNA be
different just that we'll be together I
guess I don't know because the
communication isn't going to get better
on its own
no and you're going to wake up and
realize you waited your whole life to
live and you'll be 53 years old
yeah and then what suddenly he's going
to be like all right let's play checkers
every evening
together
right and vice versa you're just going
to want like all right now we can have
sex all the time really like that's just
not just gonna
happen
right I I I
I mean yeah how can I help I I I is it
too late for counseling should we do
counseling like you haven't even had the
conversation
yet that's I'm trying that's that's what
I'm just kind of stuck I don't know
what's so hard about the
conversation that you sit down and you
tell them hey for 15 years you've done
what you want to do I've built an
amazing career and amazing life here I
want you home you got six months to wrap
it up I don't care how much money we
lose I want you
or honey you've worked your butt off 15
years hanging from highres doing
whatever it is you do I'm quitting all
this stuff I'm
out yeah or the third option is hey I've
been a single mom for 15 years you've
been a rough neck for 15 years all by
yourself and we get together
for we hook up a couple of times a month
and we sit by each other at graduation I
love you always will but this marriage
is over let's just be grown-ups about it
because I love my career too much you
love your career too much and this farm
and I've got half of my life left to
live and I don't want to be third place
behind this fantasy you have about being
a farmer and your out of town
job and you don't want to be second
place to or third place to my role is
mom and dad that I created and my job as
a
whatever right that's the third
option but I don't think it's time for
counseling yet because y'all haven't
even told each other the
truth and again the conversation needs
to be have for sure are you gonna do it
because I'm sure he's got his stuff to
say too doesn't he oh I'm sure yeah it
needs to happen it definitely needs to
happen I don't it's either that or walk
away I mean those are really in my eyes
the only two options I know but I don't
think he realizes how close you are to
option
b do you already have
somebody nope not even a little bit nope
what about over 15
years never what about
him
same are you positive I'm positive what
are you scared of
then this usually happens somebody's
this scared to have this conversation
for this long is they're scared of an
abusive response or they're scared of
something they're going to find and
they'd rather no I'm I'm scared of
probably a
failing that my
marriage I have come from a background
of a very strong marriage
parents have been married over you know
well over 50 years I know but you're not
living their
life and this is like a conversation
with my son when I'm looking at like a
worksheet with a zero on it and I'm
looking at two missing assignments and
another worksheet with a 50 on it and he
says I'm so scared of failing and I look
at him and say you
are because the marriage isn't this
thing that's way over there the marriage
is the telling the truth the marriage is
the phone calls the marriage is
sacrifice the marriage is I don't care
what job I have nothing's worth
you and that's both of
you so like marriage isn't this thing
over here it's a thousand different
decisions y'all make along the
way and it's a choice to always be in
service to and him always be in service
to and somewhere along the way y'all
started being service to yourselves and
here we
are
I would be less worried about you
failing in being scared of failing a
marriage and more scared of you waking
up being 45 years old on an island which
is what I think you've done
right and your kids acted as a Xanax for
15 years of loneliness and isolation
and being by yourself
Fair
yes
I think it's time to set up the
conversation and I would recommend it I
mean after this long I'd recommend
writing it down you might take two or
three drafts of this but I would write
it
down and I would give him a heads up and
say hey we need to have a conversation
about the state of our marriage and the
state of us staying together what what
what yeah we need to have a conversation
about the state of our marriage I
haven't told you everything over the
last 15 years and I got to put
everything out on the table and I hope
you'll honor me and do the same
thing but something's got to give
because the whole thing's about to fall
over and I don't know another way to do
that I
don't but a fear of
failure every day every week every month
is actually creating the future you're
terrified of
having have the hard conversation and if
it reveals a marriage that's an ash
y'all can decide to build something new
and it's going to be real hard but it
can absolutely be done or if you reveal
a marriage Hanging On by a thread and
both of you are all in and he's like oh
my gosh I'll quit today cool or you say
I'm out cool or both of you say I love
my job I love my job I love our we love
our jobs more than we love this thing
that we've created y'all need to be
honest and have that conversation
too I think the time for avoidance is
over we have to head directly into this
hard conflict and come up with some
solutions and by the way and you're not
the only one most people on the planet
need to do that right now head towards
the
storm thanks for the
call